flooding continues along the river seven
pushing water into communities built
along its banks after a barrage of
storms a truly destructive force
oh god i haven't even been in here
okay oh
siobhan connor shows us around her
family home in shrewsbury
it has been flooded 17 times in the last
25 years i think people don't realize
until you're in this you know it's not a
case of
getting some flash and cleaning you know
it really is
this is
sewage you know this is over spilled i
mean look at the color of it this is
toilet water you know you know that
we're stood in and it's in your home
she is exhausted and angry
how can you kind of where do you start
figuring out where the water comes from
when you've done everything you can to
mitigate flooding and to protect your
home i mean it's just heartbreaking
in nearby bewdley emergency workers
check on houses next to temporary
barriers that didn't hold the water back
scientists have warned that flood risks
are increasing as climate change drives
more frequent and intense rainfall it
makes these permanent barriers which
held firm on the other side of the river
even more important
that's why the government's recently
announced a 5 billion pound national
flood defense strategy to help build
more things like this to help
communities adapt but the blunt truth is
that they can't possibly hold back all
the water or protect everyone's homes
the environment agency knows things are
not going to get easier it's always very
worrying especially when you get named
storms one after the other we've seen
some record levels on our gauging
stations up in the top of the river
seven when i first started 20 years ago
this would have been you know one in a
career event and i've had three in the
last three years
up and down this river it may be days
before the waters recede and the lengthy
and expensive cleanup begins but they
will come again and again potentially an
increasingly common feature of our
warming world
hannah thomas peter sky news imbuedly